quick note before things get started
while i will be addressing certain
issues that i have and some of the
reporting that has gone on with
everything and also some of the
incredibly messy issues in regards to
conflicting stories around some of this
i do not wish anyone to take anything
contained in this as an attempt to
defend ezra miller from any of the
allegations i'm going to be talking
about i'm trying to add full context and
as much nuance as i feel the issue
warrants but none of this is intended to
defend them so i'd really appreciate not
being accused of that
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
okay so ezra miller's problems have
taken a turn for the
with fresh allegations if you don't
remember what went on with them before
you can check out the video i did back
in april but short version
is they caused a pretty sizable stir
rand a sustained one at that in hawaii
being thrown out of multiple bars
eventually arrested having a restraining
order issued against them by the couple
that they were staying with on the
island though that was later dropped
there was uh later on an additional
chair throwing incident since i made
that video but it that was pretty much
in line with what had been going on and
i didn't feel that it warranted a
follow-up video but this
yeah okay i kind of have to talk about
this not because i want to
and because i really
i really don't want to become a
celebrity drama channel i really do not
rather i need to do a follow up because
the angle at which i tend to view these
things is from the impact on upcoming
films and future projects now
by the end of the previous video i
stated my belief that while miller was
destined to be dropped from both the
fantastic beasts and the dc movies
franchises going forward the films
they'd appeared in wouldn't really be
affected in the case of fantastic beasts
the secretions of dumbly bum it was
because that movie was only weeks away
from release when all this happened
in the case of the flash even though
that film still isn't due out until next
year i still predicted no changes
because the filming and the editing was
completely done
and it was only effects work that was
left to be accomplished between now and
the release
and between the cost of the movie the
fact that they would have had to
basically reshoot the entire thing in
order to try and recast miller and how
much had already been lost over the
years of development hell and how many
false starts the thing had
i said that it wouldn't be worth it to
warner brothers to sink any more money
into the thing than was absolutely
necessary and inside sources from last
month backed up my assertions on this
i mean there's no doubt warner brothers
really wanted miller to stay out of
trouble between now and the release so
that they can hope people start to
forget about the hawaii stuff but even
if things went south i had a hard time
believing that would severely disrupt
the plans well
the new allegations might just do it
strap in for this one folks we have
a lot to go over
so
earlier this month chase ironize and
sarah jumping eagle filed for a petition
for a protective order for their child
who they claim has been living with
miller and whose safety they currently
fear now there's been a lot of reporting
on this and some of it has been
pretty sloppy there's been a lot of very
eye-catching and provocative terms
thrown around in news coverage terms
like
kidnapping and grooming
now before i get any further into this i
want to be
really clear about something
i don't know
what happened
between the person we're going to be
talking about and ezra miller
nobody does
and therefore i am not going to
speculate on the accuracy of any of
these allegations i am going to be as
plain as i can about what's been said
while acknowledging some of the
carelessness
in the reporting that's been going on
what do i mean by that
okay well take the fact that the
individual in question one tocata
ironize has been referred to in some
stories and even in headlines as a
teenager they are 18 years old which is
yes technically a teenager but it also
makes them legally an adult and teenager
as a word it's used for people as young
as 13. so do you see how that term
especially in a headline is potentially
misleading even if it's technically
accurate because it has the potential to
create an image in a reader's mind of
someone a fair bit younger than is
actually involved
yeah that's the kind of stuff i'm going
to be
pulling at a little bit as i go not
because i'm trying to defend ezra miller
because i'm
i'm more than fed up with them at this
point but rather because i firmly
believe it is important to be accurate
lest the facts get twisted up into
something even more sensational than
what they actually are
the facts as i have been able to find
them are
more than enough
on their own
so
i need to establish a couple of things
about toccata ironize first i want to
note it's possible that they're no
longer going by that first name i've
seen several news outlets state that
they now prefer the name gibson
however
none of those outlets provided sourcing
on that name and i couldn't find
anything on their admittedly rather
sparse social media accounts about that
so
i have referred to them as toccata iron
eyes because that's the best information
i have and if ultimately that proves to
be inaccurate i do apologize for it now
you may have noticed that i've been
using they them pronouns and that part
really isn't in dispute even the quotes
that have emerged from the protective
order petition that was written by their
parents use they them pronouns and that
petition also openly acknowledges that
they identify as non-binary queer and
gay i could go off on how many outlets
are using the wrong pronouns to refer to
them but i'm going to try and stay
focused here so a bit of background
toccata ironize is a member of the
standing rock sioux tribe which you
might recall made headlines back in 2016
when they protested the building of an
oil pipeline through tribal lands a
battle which is still ongoing in the
courts by the way as the tribe is
continuing to fight against the now
completed pipeline but back in 2016 iron
eyes was 12 years old and became
actively involved in the protest making
headlines at the time and in later years
becoming even more of an activist and
meeting with greta thundberg
this is also allegedly the point at
which ezra miller enters the picture
miller amongst other public figures went
to the standing rock protests in a show
of support
now miller is 11 years older than iron
eyes so they were 23 at the time that
the two met
from there they remained in touch with
ironized traveling along with other
members of the tribe to the premiere of
the first fantastic beast film in 2017.
now the petition claims that at that
time miller attempted to share a bed
with iron eyes but was prevented from
doing so by chaperone there isn't a lot
of details that i've been able to find
more than that
i really haven't had much luck nailing
down precisely at what point iron eyes
began living and traveling with miller
but it appears to be following their
dropping out of college last year a
college they've been attending for two
years with alleged financial assistance
from miller now iron eyes and their
exact birthday is not public record but
given the year of birth that i have been
able to find as listed as 2004
that would have made them 17 at the time
that they dropped out of college
assuming that the date that i found is
accurate even though it's incomplete
since that time they've been traveling
with miller between london hawaii new
york and miller's residence in vermont
and no it's not a part of vermont
anywhere near me
don't ask
okay so so the the petition for the
protective order i've alluded to a few
things that are in it already but i need
to be really upfront about something i
haven't read
the actual court document
i would very much like to
but i can't find it
it was issued by a tribal court it's not
publicly available
now clearly some news outlets have
gotten their hands on at least portions
of it as they quote directly from it
but none have made whatever
documentation they've managed to get
their hands on viewable in its entirety
well i mean
it's also possible that with my adhd the
thing is actually available somewhere
super accessible and obvious and i just
can't think of it but
i did my best okay now this is uh also
where i want to kind of pause and make a
note of some other terms that have been
appearing in news coverage that feel
like they're being
let's go with employed a bit carelessly
kind of like how i mentioned with the
term
teenager
firstly
there's the word grooming
now i'll have a bit more to say on this
later on but the main thing i want to
bring up here is that so far as i can
tell
the word grooming doesn't appear
anywhere in the petition now you're
probably asking you just said you
haven't read the thing because you can't
find it how do you know that
and you know what fair question
but here's the thing
i noticed in a lot of coverage
that direct quotes from the petition
were frequently pulled
things like the following
physically and emotionally abusing
cult-like and psychologically
manipulative and controlling behavior
and statements like these would appear
in quotations
right next to the word grooming but
grooming was never in quotes now being
unable to read the whole thing myself
that may still be an accurate summation
of accusations since terms like sexual
predatory behavior and patterns of
corrupting a minor are put in quotes and
therefore most likely appear in the
petition
it just struck me as odd
that the single most inflammatory term
that shows up in most of these articles
and is often in the headlines
appears to be the wordings of news
outlets and not of the actual petition
hey it's me from the editing phase so
something that i want to note here that
i'm actually going to bring up again
later but i want to put it here as well
and it'll just be reiterated later my
issue is not with how accurate the term
groomer is or isn't especially at this
point in time where at the time that i'm
recording this voiceover we have had
additional uh things come forward and
additional allegations from another
person this time again a 12 year old
which would indicate a pattern so i'm
not debating the accuracy of the term my
concern is with the use of the word
specifically because of the manner in
which it is currently being used as a
weapon against queer people and i know
that no matter what i say there are
going to be a million people in my
comments shouting at me you should just
call a groomer or groomer but what i
would point out is that even if all of
this is true the daily beast which
covered the latest allegations in which
i'll be touching on later on
they managed to discuss everything going
on be pretty thorough and not once use
that term as it did not appear quoted or
as any kind of summation of allegations
and no i'm not trying to police people
saying they can never use the word again
i'm saying that under the current
climate it frustrates me to see it
become the go-to word at a time when it
is being deployed so drastically against
the entire queer population and trans
people in particular simply for
political clout i hope in future to see
more caution used in its deployment
which has not been the case here now
some even less scrupulous outlets are
putting terms like kidnapping in their
headlines and that wording doesn't
really even appear to have standing as
being a summation of the petition's
accusation so far as i can tell
there are no accusations of actual
kidnapping instead the parents are
accusing miller of brainwashing their
child and to be controlling their
decisions
and at this point it's worth coming back
to the issue of age not just the age gap
but as noted
there's accusations of inappropriate
behavior from times in which iron ice
was definitely a minor but right now
they're currently 18 which makes them
legally an adult now there appears to be
a quirk and tribal law that makes them
still under the legal guardianship of
their parents or at least that's what's
being stated by chase iron eyes uh their
father who is an attorney now not
knowing how to even begin looking up
tribal law and lacking the education
needed to parse it even if i could
i can't independently verify that myself
one way or the other but that's why
ironizes parents are filing this despite
them being 18.
so the intention of the petition is to
basically serve as a restraining order
to keep miller and ironic separated
until a formal hearing on the matter can
take place which is currently set
for a court date of july 12th but then
we get into the issue that um at present
nobody's been able to locate miller or
iron eyes in order to serve them with
the court documents which
that's probably where the uh kidnapping
shows up in some reporting but again
there's no formal accusation of that and
at time of recording at least this is
not being investigated as a kidnapping
and now i get to drop in after having
shot this to let you know about some of
the additional things that have come out
since now at present things haven't
really changed in regards to miller and
ironize however there has now been an
additional filing for a protective order
for a completely new person this
happened in massachusetts filed by some
parents on behalf of their 12 year old
now none of the names have been released
nor should they be that having been said
i'm not going to go through this aspect
by aspect i will put a link in the
description to the daily beast article
that covers it what i will say at this
point is that much like with the
protective order that i've been talking
about so far these are allegations these
have not have been investigated by the
police that does not mean they did not
happen it just means that all we have
right now is one side however that one
side is incredibly consistent with the
kind of stuff i've already been talking
about both now and previously about
miller's behavior and such things would
appear to include an incredibly short
fuse when it came to issues of race or
gender yelling at people that they
didn't know there's an accusation that
they actually had a firearm on them in
the house where this occurred all that
having been said the actual protective
order focuses on their what has been
described as creepy interest in an at
the time 11 year old non-binary child
miller did apparently return to the same
house at a later date and did so without
incident but that really isn't relevant
given the nature of the accusations in
this complaint so if again if both sets
of allegations are mostly or entirely
true then yeah we now have a pattern of
predatory behavior from miller which
doesn't really impact my assessments
that i'm going to be doing for the
remainder of this video but it does lean
things just even more strongly that
there is no
really good best case scenario in this
it's all bad it's just a question of how
bad and one other thing i want to note
when comparing this to the protective
order that i'm largely talking about
here involving iron eyes there is one
major key difference and that is the
fact that as i'm about to get into there
is some dispute from the person in
question who actually claims they do not
need protection here in this case the 12
year old themself has expressed fear and
concern about what went on so there is
no miscommunication or garbled messaging
from the people involved who are
actually speaking out about this and of
course miller continues to elude
authorities so we have no idea what they
have to say and honestly at this point i
don't think i want to hear it even when
they start talking now this is where
things start to get really muddy oh yeah
yeah we still got a ways to go
iron eyes whose parents have made it
known doesn't carry a phone of their own
has made two public statements through
their instagram since the start of this
the first was a written statement in
which they assert that they are not in
danger that miller is a source of loving
support and invaluable protection during
a time when they were mourning the loss
of a friend following their leaving
college
they accused their parents of betrayal
toxicity
transphobia
and they assert their autonomy stating i
am an adult and i deserve to feel
authority in my own body
the authenticity of this statement was
almost immediately brought into question
including by sarah jumping eagle their
mother
that happened during an interview with
the la times now several days later
iron eyes then posted a short video on
the same instagram account not providing
much in the way of additional details
but asserting that the words which
appeared in the statement were their own
i'd like to clarify
that
they
are in fact directly
from me
nobody is controlling my instagram
account
uh if you're reading them you might have
noticed some of the comments on that
video are trying to assess their
competency or honesty and what they're
saying but as i do not know them and
have no meaningful point of reference
for their normal patterns of speech i
will not be indulging in any such
speculation here
so
as i said
this muddies things a fair bit
since there are now public statements
from the alleged victim who appears to
want no part of their parents right now
and this
is where i'm going to come as close to
speculation as i'm comfortable and i'm
really only doing this
to acknowledge what a mess of possible
things there are at play so
it's fairly easy from the perspective of
the parents to claim that these
statements were coerced in some way by
miller as that pattern of behavior would
very much be in line with the
allegations of the petition and if
if
those allegations are accurate it would
make sense to question these statements
and how much they can or should be
trusted or believed
however
on the other side of things if
again if
ironizes accusations of transphobia and
psychological manipulation on the part
of their parents are accurate then it
becomes a matter of a young adult
struggling to be free of a controlling
family
so to pick a specific point just to
illustrate what a
cluster this is
let's examine the accusation by iron
eyes that their parents or at least
their father specifically is transphobic
now
as i mentioned before the petition uses
their correct pronouns and acknowledges
the parents as understanding their child
to be non-binary queer
gay
which
would seem to preclude the parents being
transphobic
but then
there's this bit that appears as a
lifted quote from the petition
ezra has decided that tokada is
non-binary transgender it's sentences
like that which make me
really wish i had the full petition to
try and get some context on that because
i really want to know precisely how
chase iron eyes distinguishes between
non-binary something he appears to
accept and non-binary transgender
something he's implying is being thrust
onto his child by miller and carries an
inherent negative connotation
oh i should probably define some turns
here okay crash course non-binary is an
umbrella term a bit like transgender it
refers to not adhering to seeing oneself
as being on the gender binary of either
male or female now the term non-binary
is used as an identity in and of itself
but also as a spectrum upon which lies
many more specific identities and from a
strict definition it's not inaccurate to
refer to non-binary as a transgender
identity by that i mean transgender in
the broadest sense means not identifying
as the gender you were assigned at birth
it does not specifically mean
only male to female or female to male
though those are among the most common
and best known instances of being
transgender but simply put
nobody has non-binary as their assigned
gender at birth so anyone who identifies
as non-binary can be said to have
transitioned from their assigned gender
to a non-binary identity not all would
choose those words
to describe themselves but
that is not inaccurate and this is why
chase iron eyes distinguishing between
non-binary and non-binary transgender
is really kind of confusing to me
because i don't know what he's doing if
i were to hazard a guess
it's possible that it's meant to imply
that iron eyes is or is intending in the
future to undergo transitional treatment
uh like say hormones or surgeries which
some but not all non-binary people do
opt to do in some form or another but
honestly regardless of the specific
meaning of the distinction and what he
meant by it from the limited context we
have it does appear that their parents
are framing transgender in the negative
even though they are supportive
apparently of non-binary so it's
possible
that iron eyes had a non-binary identity
that their parents were supportive of
but has since become begun a journey
beyond the limits of their parents
comfort and if
if that is the case there is a chance
transphobia may be mixed in with genuine
concern on the part of the parents
add to the mix that the parents have
apparently attempted to obtain
guardianship over iron eyes before and
have been largely blocked by an
inability to serve papers properly so a
bit of a pattern there the parents also
claimed to have conducted a wellness
visit in santa monica during which sarah
jumping eagle that's ironic's mother
claims to have been assaulted by miller
with an incident report allegedly being
filed that's another document i couldn't
find publicly available records for
there's also accusations in the petition
of providing iron eyes with drugs such
as marijuana and lsd which would fit
with the cult-like accusation but then
again if ironize's statement is true
those are also the kind of accusations
that are really easy to pile on with
little evidence especially given
miller's previous arrest for marijuana
possession
additionally the parents note that quote
if anybody questions ezra's actions they
say they're being racist or transphobic
i'm not entirely sure where the racism
enters into it unless they meant
anti-semitic
as miller is of jewish descent on their
father's side but on the idea of
accusing anyone they don't like of
transphobia that is a tactic that does
exist although not employed nearly as
often as some
culture critics would claim
but from another angle it's also known
tactic to preemptively claim someone
will just shout transphobia when
confronted so that any actual
transphobia can't be called out without
the people doing the call out being
brought into immediate question nearly
everything that's known or has been
stated by either party can be viewed to
fit an opposing narrative without much
effort and it pretty much all centers
around who people choose to assume is
more truthful iron eyes or their parents
and i have absolutely no way of knowing
how much of if any of these possible
views or scenarios are true that's even
before we get into the fact that even if
ironize is truthful in their assessment
of their parents it's still at best
extremely eyebrow raising if not deeply
concerning that this reprieve from an
allegedly bad home life
happened at the hands of someone 11
years their senior who's been in their
social orbit since they were 12 and has
a history of disruptive and at times
violent behavior
it's not impossible
for miller to be the safe harbor that
iron eyes is claiming them to be
but
it's kind of hard right now to just
assume that to be the case especially
when the two of them can't even be found
to receive the court documents
which brings us
firmly and finally back
to ezra miller
now going forward i am going to shift
focus because
i know i had a lot to cover as far as
the petition the response and all that
freaking mess but
from here out i'm talking about what i
really want to focus on now that the
context is out of the way
what the hell happens next as far as
public image for miller and the release
of the flash goes and no
to the asshats in the comments that
doesn't mean that i care more about a
movie release than the safety of a human
it means that this is supposed to be a
geeky pop culture channel and i'm
frankly more comfortable speculating on
the actions of a soulless corporation
than on those of human beings i hope for
the safety of all involved i shouldn't
have to state that plainly but i will i
hope whatever the truth is it becomes
clearer and that all are extricated from
any unhealthy situations they may have
been in the past or maybe in now
okay
okay
so the reason i couldn't ignore this
despite really hating drilling down into
people's lives the way these things
always necessitate is because
this is the one thing that i can think
of other than maybe an accusation of
homicide that might actually force
warner brothers to alter its plans for
the flash
now
as i said before the amount of money
that's been sunk into this
already
means
it's going to be an uphill battle to
truly turn a profit and that was before
any of this started
as a result
warner brothers is going to be extremely
reluctant to throw any more money at
this thing than they already have you
know understanding that they're still
gonna have to throw the standard
marketing costs at it i mean heck the
issues in hawaii probably already meant
the company wasn't going to be safe
being able to send miller out on press
junkets because a big chunk of the
questions would be about their legal
troubles instead of the movie
any
company would be reluctant to spend any
more money than they have to and trying
to remove miller be it by reshooting the
entire film from scratch or even trying
to replace them digitally
would drive up the cost of this already
very expensive movie by quite a bit and
push back the release days by at least
another year probably more
yet
at the same time
they've sunk far too much money into
this to just mothball the thing and
write it off if they don't release it
they can't recoup
any of it and the pressure is even
greater than it would be otherwise due
to the recent merger between warner
brothers and discovery
shake-ups restructurings and even
firings are extremely common during
these kinds of transitions the head of
warner brothers picture group is already
being replaced and this is absolutely
the worst time for an arm of the studio
like the dc movies to appear to be badly
managed or in shambles so the question
becomes
what's worse
risking the release of a film where the
star actor stands accused of
just about the worst thing possible for
a family tent pole film
or
spending potentially
millions tens of millions maybe even
over 100 million more dollars trying to
scrub them from the project and
virtually guaranteeing that the movie
will never be able to make its money
back or just write the entire thing off
now before another penny gets thrown at
a sinking ship and honestly i don't know
what the best option is
this already messy situation also has a
rather nasty
political edge to it even beyond the
usual rage merchants shouting wokeness
at any casting that isn't a
cis straight white dude with a perfect
jawline
because um
in case you hadn't noticed
groomer
has become
the current buzzword among the far right
when it comes to referring to the
lgbtqia plus community and to anything
related to trans people in particular
which again it may well be an accurate
summation of the allegations but that
specific word is being used as a weapon
right now and having it looming over the
star of a major film means that if
warner brothers does nothing a
significant political force will accuse
the entire organization of shielding
predators something that has been a
genuine hollywood issue as the metoo
movement has shown in recent years but
then again warner brothers has extremely
fresh memories of making a call before
things were fully played out and then
having that bite them in the ass in
terms of public opinion with the
dismissal of johnny depp from the third
fantastic beast film and the retaining
of amber heard for the second aquaman
and there's a debate to be had over how
likely an actual boycott would be to
happen at all and how impactful it would
be if it did happen
and that's a debate which will not be
had here thank you very much
but regardless all of this is bad press
it just creates more and more negative
feelings toward miller directly and the
flash by association
warner brothers is
really in a no-win situation here
i mean barring a miracle like miller and
iron is being found and the parents
dropping the petition and everybody
involved publicly stating it's okay
everything's fine
and since i'm not expecting that to
happen
what i am expecting is one of two things
either warner brothers will act pretty
quickly to the point that i may end up
having to add a supplementary material
to this after i film it
or they will drag their feet for months
basically it depends on how willing the
people making the decisions are to bite
the bullet and take the blame for the
fallout and to be clear
usually people at the executive level
are pretty reluctant to do that
if the decision is made that this whole
thing just keeps getting worse and they
need to pull the plug before the next
disaster
if there's any decision like that made i
expect the announcement within the next
week
to come and confirm that there is a
delay or maybe even that the movie is
skipping theatrical altogether and it's
being dumped on hbo max which would help
it avoid the expense of the theatrical
run and the associated marketing push
and if that happens
also expect a pretty swift change of
management over the dc film properties
because
making that call would basically be an
admission that they gave up trying to
fix it
failing
that i think warner brothers is going to
stall for as long as they think they can
get away with in a desperate hope that
things either get better or at least go
quiet
it's still about a year away from the
current release date for the flash they
may
honestly hold out in
desperate hope that the headlines will
stop maybe by august
and then they'll plan the marketing
campaign around emphasizing everything
other
than ezra miller so expect michael
keaton to be put front and center and
for any other hidden or surprise
appearances to get spoiled and used in
marketing in an attempt to reclaim the
conversation
because it's pretty rare for executives
to admit defeat if there's even a
sliver
of a chance things might still work out
i mean you can just look at netflix
pretending everything was fine for over
a year and only admitting to being in
trouble when it became literally
impossible to hide that fact you can
check out uh my video on that mess if
you need a refresher on any of that
as for ezra miller
i mean they're pretty much done
at this point
i never believed for a second that
warner brothers would keep them on past
this one flash film that was already
shot even before
this whole mess happened from a pr
standpoint
miller is radioactive not just because
of what they're alleged to have done but
because the headlines don't stop coming
i mean honestly you'd be surprised the
scandals that can be recovered from so
long as the person in question keeps
their head down and stays out of trouble
for long enough and doesn't generate any
new headlines and miller seems utterly
incapable of that at this point
right now the only real question is
whether or not jail is in their future
and that
if it happens may not even have anything
to do with this petition because
remember this isn't an arrest warrant
it's a restraining order these
allegations are not currently part of a
criminal complaint that said there's
still lingering fallout from everything
that went on in hawaii i don't think
that's finished playing out yet and a
criminal investigation spawning from
this protective order isn't out of the
question especially if miller and
ironize fail to appear in court
now
i expect more stuff will come out in the
coming days and weeks and to be clear i
have absolutely no plans to keep on top
of it all
i tackled this one because of how it
impacts the flash because geek media is
what i'm actually here to talk about
i know i spent more time talking about
the protective order and the people
involved in it
but i really feel that all the context
was necessary given how shallow a lot of
takes out there are right now
but
until warner brothers makes
whatever its next move ends up being
don't expect me to jump on every little
drip of new information and fresh
allegations that comes out about ezra
miller
i'm not going to say that i don't care
but i am going to say i
really
do not want to talk about it anymore
unless i absolutely have to
and i felt i had to this time
but what are your thoughts on any of
this
absolute mess please remember to refrain
from personal attacks that includes
against me
miller iron eyes their parents or even
the people at warner brothers no
personal attacks
please i know this is
a lot
that i've gone over
and people probably have very strong
opinions and that's fine just be
respectful when you express them if you
can adhere to that drop something down
the comments and let's talk about it
patreon is what pays my bills and allows
and allows me to
dedicate an entire day to researching
and shooting and editing this
and also on patreon uh you get early
access to videos like this one and can
see them ahead of everybody else but uh
even if you can't support me on patreon
there's a bunch of links to other stuff
i do there is merch including pride
merch uh as well as books i've written
and all this other stuff but
what i really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right i've got thanks to give for my
patreon supporters robin moore zubin
fula tarak the thing that goes doink in
the anime oliver b linda walters
imudelki the oath of boyd tt for knobby
lax the poodle zach idolin tracy
scrabbit angry casperl
toku bl whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shayla gourley and brendan larose
the rats and i thank you
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]